all right let's talk about aircraft
ownership and maintenance some of this
stuff actually oddly enough is on the
test what does it cost to own an
airplane most people say I can't afford
that but then you see them buy a brand
new car or renovate their kitchen for
$200,000 so I don't know what their
excuse is it's actually not expensive to
own a four-seat airplane there's so many
out there there were more pilots in the
70s and 80s when these airplanes were
built in large quantities the owner of
East Coast Aero Club Mark he says that
in the 80s there was a waiting list even
for its high down at Hanscom now you
know there's ample parking the hangar
space is still a little bit tight but if
you just want to get a Cessna and pay
it's actually a lot cheaper to tie a
system down at Hanscom than it is to
park a car in Cambridge and there's
plenty of room you know he said every
every firefighter every country's to
have a family airplane so the airplanes
are relatively inexpensive to buy twenty
thirty thousand dollars for something
that's air worthy for VFR use for basic
VFR use and you can see the prices here
the depreciation would be pretty close
to zero for that those lower end
airplanes anyway all that said it's
still cheaper to rent from a flight
school if you're gonna fly you know 100
hours a year you know paying 150 or 200
dollars an hour to a flight school is
still cheaper and it's a lot easier for
people for whom owning may actually make
a little bit of rational sense it never
truly makes sense compared to just
getting everywhere in your Toyota Camry
that if you fly a whole ton you know
more than 200 hours a year and the fixed
costs of insurance and storage and stuff
won't kill you
if you have to use the airplane to make
regular long trip somewhere and then
just park it away from the home Airport
then it makes sense and a lot of people
also
you know you can't you can't fly if you
if you have multiple airplanes you can't
fly them all at the same time and even
one airplane it's a little bit hard to
use every day the way you would use a
car so partnerships with two to four
people are pretty common and that costs
cuts the cost dramatically without
really impairing the utility I shared an
airplane for years with a guy and I
don't think we ever conflicted on when
we wanted to use the plane alright this
is some stuff that you want to know a
little bit if you're an owner it's
really critical and if you're a renter
some of the stuff is still relevant so
the owner or operator if you think about
a leaseback airplane to the flight
school the lease back owner is you know
an individual perhaps and the flight
school becomes the operator and they're
the ones who are primarily responsible
for making sure the airplane is air
worthy that it gets its annual
inspection and that it has a logbook
however the pilot is also responsible
and you know if the pilot knows that
something is inoperative and it's not
required then it's it's still legal to
fly the airplane and a lot of
circumstances as long as that piece of
equipment is placarded in up and you
know maybe the breaker is pulled for
example on a GPS unit that's not working
and after maintenance then a private
pilot with no passengers can make a
entry in the log book saying that the
test flight was done the core inspection
is every 12 months for a privately owned
airplane it has to have an annual
inspection typically it won't fly a
whole lot more than 100 hours during
that year if it's just one person flying
it but
the 100-hour requirement only becomes
necessary when the airplane is operated
commercially like at a flight school so
that's 100 hours of flight time not
engine running time so you know if it's
taxing around the airport the engine
might be running for 120 or 130 hours to
build up a hundred hours of flight time
for heavy you say well god these
airlines you know they must have to tear
the airplane apart open all in the
instruction panel's every week or two
Jet's have their own maintenance
schedule that supersedes this fa
guidance even modest-sized jets often
have a 300 or 600 hour service interval
the Pilatus pc-12 it was recently
extended to 300 hours for example okay
Tina covered this before the transponder
has to be inspected and sort of
recertified every couple of years
emergency locator transmitters if it's a
civil airplane 91 207 says it has to
have an ELT
except in certain circumstances so
gliders helicopters things like that
don't really need it I don't think maybe
the glider does I don't think so
so the essays you know really wants to
ensure that every aircraft that's flying
around in the US has a comprehensive
logbook going back to the birth of the
aircraft to the birth of the propeller
and the birth of the engine engines when
they get remanufactured by somebody like
lycoming or
Continental they get a zero time log
book so that logbook my only go back you
know four or five years but the logbook
for the airframe should go back to when
it was made if an airplane you know if
the logbook ever gets lost the airplane
is significantly devalued because stuff
has to be reconstructed and you can
never really be sure what's happened to
it okay there are airworthiness
directives that legally have to be
applied to aircraft as a manufacturer
issues a service bulletin you don't have
to do that especially if you're not
operating the airplane you know
commercially like as an airline or
charter but air worthies airworthiness
directives are mandatory so let's think
see if i can think of an example i think
there were some cessna seats that were
sliding back some people were trying to
fly their cessna and the seat wasn't
really locked into position so that's
the kind of thing where an air
worthiness directive would be negotiated
between Cessna and the FAA and it would
be issued and they might say you know
within the next ten flight hours you
have to go and get new seat rails for
your assessment to make sure that it
doesn't slide back inadvertently if
there's a plane you know if there's
something really seriously mich may
issue an emergency air worthiness
directive and say everything's grounded
until you apply this fix or change
here's just an example actually what did
we find here
this was for serious in flight cabin
door separation that's not good
one was a total separation and one was
retained by the door struttin we're
issuing this 880 to prevent in-flight
failure of the cabin door okay
well it's nice to have two doors I guess
that's the takeaway from this one I
don't know what they said that you have
to do yeah threads leaves blah blah blah
but it says within 50 hours see that
within the next 50 hours time and
service so they don't consider that an
emergency and actually yeah if you ever
do take off your airplane don't slam an
aircraft door they tend to be fragile
the latches various techniques have been
tried over the years by various
manufacturers none of them are as
foolproof as car doors because you know
they don't have the weight budget that a
car has so if a door does pop up and
in-flight it's actually not hazardous as
long as you're not so startled that you
do something crazy on takeoff they
usually they'll usually pop open just as
you're climbing out and you're like whoa
what's that noise anyway just remember
as Tina said keep flying the airplane
and don't overly don't over focus on
something that's not related to the
aircraft attitude and power okay part 43
is mostly stuff that certified a and P
mechanics need to know these are it's
illegal actually for this is one this is
one reason why owning an airplane is
better than owning a boat it's illegal
for you to work on your own airplane for
oh that's you have to have an FAA
certified mechanic do it you can't spend
every weekend monkeying with your
airplane there are a handful of things
it's pilots are allowed to do you can
replace a tire you can add oil you can
there's an enumerated list 31 items a
lot of those are kind of more it can
change the spark plug a lot of them are
more related to bush pilots you know if
you're up in Alaska or northern
Minnesota or out in the middle of Maine
and you want to change something you
know instead of being stuck you can
carry a spark plug and a wrench and get
yourself back to the hangar but it's
unconventional for people with certified
airplanes to do much in the way of
maintenance there are one exception is
owner assisted annual some people who
are very mechanically inclined like to
work with an A&P and help out so yeah if
you do this stuff you have to assign it
off by making a logbook entry with your
certificate number and what kind of
certificate so you can't you know if you
change the oil you still have to log it
even though you're not a mechanic he'd
just say I'm a pilot and here's my pilot
certificate number all right if that's
too much work and you still really just
want to own an airplane because you want
to say that I own an airplane you can
buy an airplane and then if you're not
gonna fly at 200 hours a year or more
you can lease it to a flight school and
let the flight school be responsible for
the maintenance a lot of people do this
to take advantage to depreciation let's
say their medical doctor they start a
side business working with a flight
school and they're now in the aircraft
rental business and they take on 100%
deduction for their airplane it hasn't
really been completely tested by the IRS
leasing is supposed to be a passive loss
and you're not supposed to offset it
against active income so people come up
with various gimmicks where the flight
school is marketing their aircraft for
rental to other people anyway they're
taking a you know seven or eight hundred
thousand dollar write-off in one year
against their you know million dollar
income a supposition and now they have a
free airplane and that's why you can go
to the flight school
rent one of these beautiful new
airplanes for $250 an hour it sounds
like a lot but take advantage of it
because they're basically giving you the
airplane for free okay what if that's
not enough work
we'll go to Oshkosh in July I'll be
there and we can go check out all the
KITT airplanes and you can meet people
who say they've spent 13 years building
the airplane and now they're finally
flying it so in theory the airplane has
to be built by this the intent was some
person who was then gonna fly it had to
build half of it but you know LLC's are
also people as far as the regulations
are concerned so basically the LLC
becomes the Builder of record and the
LLC is formed between somebody who you
know actually knows what he or she is
doing and the pilot who just wants to
fly the cool experimental airplane and
then when the builders finished the
pilot buys out the Builder there are a
lot of limitations on experimentals oh
yeah another technique is the factory is
just build so to show that people have
done a lot of work they'll go down to
the factory and they'll change their
clothing every two hours and they'll
have all these pictures of themselves
doing various work on the aircraft and
then they can show that to the FAA and
say look I was I was putting on the
wings I was doing this I was doing that
all right you can't you can't use the
aircraft commercially and if your
passenger gets into the airplane you
know right in front of the passenger
will be the scary-looking sign that says
this is experimental doesn't meet FAA
standards so the passenger is warned
that there's a lot more risk than flying
a Cessna so you might say well you know
why is it riskier than a Cessna or a
Cirrus and I talked to I talked to Alan
Clapp Meyer about this one of the
founders of Cirrus I said how come these
experimentals have so much better
numbers for payload or speed
then you know certified plans like the
Cirrus so part of it is that they're
relieved of a lot of the forgiving nosov
certified airplanes so they're a little
bit trickier to handle you might have a
higher stall speed they're just not as
as idiot proofed and as stable as a
cessna Piper or Cirrus the other issue
is that they don't have as much
redundant structure with an experimental
you're allowed to assume that the
construction process was perfect there
were no defects there were no missing
screws then nobody dropped a tool and
damaged part of the structure during
construction with a certified airplane
you have to show to the FAA that even if
all kinds of bad stuff goes on during
manufacturing and then you know the
airplane is buttoned up so that those
parts can't really be inspected
afterwards it still meets all the
structural requirements that's why you
see these crazy you know YouTube videos
of wings being tested you know the
transport category aircraft are only
supposed to be certified two two and a
half GS and the wings don't break until
they put nine G's on them partly they're
over designing you know because it's
good engineering practice but also
because they have to over design to some
extent because it has to do two and a
half G's even if a lot of mistakes were
made during the manufacturing so the
yeah so experimentalist there's not
really a free one it's not like they're
better than assessment or piper they're
subject to kind of different different
rules and the the one element where you
know they are arguably better is that
with composites you're allowed to it's
it becomes practical to make arbitrary
shapes you know if you're fabricating
sheet metal there's a limit to how
exotic you can get at a reasonable price
whereas planes like the Cirrus and then
some of these experimentals you can have
a nice smooth skin and you can make any
shape you want
it's a closer to an ideal airfoil
but otherwise there's no free lunch if
it has better pay though that's because
they took out all the redundant
structure that makes a certified
airplane a little safer all right renter
pilots are still responsible to some
extent for this stuff you got to make
sure the aircraft is air worthy you
can't pin it all on the flight school if
you see something hanging loose or
there's no oil in it then you know it's
your responsibility to call the mechanic
over to re-secure the panel or put some
oil and you want to make sure that the
airplane has you know airworthiness
certificate the registration used to
last forever now it expires every three
years so I guess if you're at a
brand-new flight school and you don't
know everybody there it's worth at least
paying some attention to the
registration the AFM Poh or owners
manual if you want to be koloko about it
that has to be on board the aircraft
usually the weight and balance is not a
separate thing it's just inside the Poh
and you have to also have to report
accidents we'll talk about that more in
the z-plane lecture it's C playing
sloppiness in the seaplane tends to be
more likely to lead to an accident all
right so you are responsible for the
operation of the aircraft and with
responsibility comes the authority and
ability to deviate from the rules in an
emergency you can just say you know
serious 7:07 whiskey tango emergency
landing you know at this nearby Air
Force Base
and they can't really bust you for that
if later they come and say well you know
we want to know why you landed at the
Air Force Base then you have to you know
respond with you know what I need to
want to do that but if they don't
request you to do that and there's no
need
so basically you can just read the slide
but yeah I board the mission if you see
something broken during the pre-flight
all right here's an estándar
airworthiness certificate there on the
bottom right
when was it issued 1995 so I think
that's when the airplane was built the
airworthiness certificate should tell
you you know when the manufacturing
process terminated start shopping so if
you look at - controller comm that's
where your higher end aircraft are and
trade a plane is that big yellow book
that some of you guys may have seen at
flight schools Barnstorm Barnstormers
comm is the home built center before we
take questions I'll just close by
telling you all that's fine but it's not
really rational having done one iller on
roll and one loop in my life do I need a
game bird no but it's only 400 grand and
I want a game bird and wouldn't it be
cool to arrive in a game bird look at
that luggage space you could put in
probably three packs of crushproof
cigarettes and you know
a spare a spare pair of socks like
Charles Lindbergh used to travel with so
anyway yeah that ownership stuff it's
never a rational decision to buy an
aircraft but unless you're planning on
dying rich why not actually jet Aviva
has the thing their whole tagline for
this airplane brokerage is life as short
fly a jet does anyone have any exciting
questions about maintenance and your
responsibilities there's a pilot ok
there's a little bit of interaction
there between you know the pilot and the
mechanic you can't practically check
everything you have to rely on mechanics
who are generally quite reliable in
their FA certificated but you have to
have a little bit of common sense about
not accepting a broken airplane or
helicopter Oh
if you go here on your plane my friend
Kristian can answer that there may be a
youtube video but anyway I think you the
FAA is supposed to inspect at one or two
points during the construction I'm a
hundred percent sure about that but I
think that they may come in more
importantly there's like 40 hours of
flight testing that has to be done and
you can't go over populated areas during
that flight testing and you get cut
loose I think after 40 or 50 hours in
the experimental world it's never been
attractive to me I mean if you talk to
the people who do experimentals they're
really passionate about building and
tinkering they actually have very few
hours of flight time accumulated and
that becomes a problem because their
pilot even if they were a good pilot
when they started you know after
spending 13 years in a garage building
you know their pilot skills were pretty
rusty I would also recommend that you
ask Sebastian's if you guys remember
Sebastian came yesterday afternoon from
the Flying Club and he was discussing
how they're getting at that plane
refurbish their wood he had a picture
with the wing not attached and now the
the wing is attached so I believe that
he's going through that airworthiness
process right now so definitely
recommend you talk to Sebastian and then
the other thing I would just add to
aircraft ownership in general is that
there are also a lot of opportunities
where there are basically you can become
part of a group that partially owns an
airplane so there's a bunch of clubs
around here where for example there are
three planes that are owned by you know
60 people and so you kind of timeshare
those planes and a number of the other
instructors of this course have done
that so you might have heard Luke or
Marissa talk about that and so they have
some planes for example in Beverly where
there are three planes and a bunch of
people own it and so you can timeshare
the plane and they have to
be very mindful about these types of
maintenance aspects as well so it's kind
of an in-between cost of renting versus
owning your own airplane by yourself and
the and the if you want to you know the
Experimental Aircraft Association which
runs off scoffs they have chapter
meetings all over the country all the
time they're kind of the most social
folks in the aviation world so if you
want to like find out what it's like to
build your own kit airplane or design
your own airplane from scratch those
people will be happy to hang out with
you at least every month all over the
country
you